на річницю вони можуть підготувати ту чи
іншу якусь підступну
акцію наприклад
бомбардування ракетами нашої території і
Ми свідомі того що є на території
Російської Федерації деяких ракет
лишилися 8% деяких 11% порівняно з тим
що було
в них зараз План Б - це зробити розподіл
нашої країни на дві частини так званий
корейський сценарій 38 паралель фашисти
сидять в Кремлі перші фашист на
сьогоднішній день це Путін захід має
готуватися до розпаду Російської
Федерації старт цьому розвалу дав Путін
24 лютого
сьогодні ми поговоримо з Олексієм
даніловим секретарем Ради національної
безпеки Олексію за вашими даними що
Росія готує на річницю у
повномасштабного вторгнення в Україну 24
лютого
ну по-перше розуміємо що ми маємо справу
з країною для яких дати є означальної
починаючи з 17-го року у них дати
народження млиніна Потім Сталіна скоро
будуть там Путін на смерть Леніна
станіна Путіна Це для них є такі як
кроки От і звичайно для на річницю вони
можуть підготувати ту чи іншу якусь
підступну
акцію наприклад
бомбардування ракетами нашої території І
от як це вже було неодноразово або якісь
інші речі ну це природна річ і ми до
цього маємо вже ну звикнути до цього
складно тому що за кожним таким Бардо
бомбардуванням є людські втрати На жаль
от але дивіться ми Ми свідомі того з ким
ми маємо справу це те чого немає
розуміння на заході вони вважають що
росіян можна перерахувати вважаю що Їх
можна якось зробити з Росії демократичну
країну от це зробити неможливо і йдемо
розуміючи з ким ми маємо справу
Ми готуємося до будь-якого розвитку
подій які будуть найближчим часом будуть
после для нас якихось новел от тут немає
на яких напрямках росіяни опанують піти
у великий наступ І на вашу думку за
останній рік чи змінилися цілі
пріоритети РФ в Україні чи все-таки
хочуть ще взяти Київ мета
росіян вона відома це знищення нас як
держави
Богу дякуючи дякуючи нашим громадянам
нашим президенту ця мета яку вони
ставили собі 24 лютого вже Минулого року
не здійснилася і не могла здійснитися
тому що ми то розуміли як ми Готу
комісія ми розуміли чим Ми займалися цей
час
і зараз вони мають
спробу поміняти у них зараз запущено
План Б з урахуванням того що вони не
можуть зараз закупити всю нашу країну
Вони йдуть зараз по так званому
корейському сценарію задіяний величезні
групи впливу от вони
підняли Скажімо так всіх хто вважає що
тут буде мати того чи інших вплив
залучили представників людей які
працювали на Януковича працювали на
партію регіонів зараз роблять вигляд що
вони є незалежними експертами
Медведчук мав промову вчора якщо я не
помиляюсь з приводу того якесь звернення
тут до громадян України де він зрадник
постать 11 статті і де громадяни України
мені складно сказати чомусь вони
вважають що тут хтось має його слухати а
в них зараз План Б - це зробити розподіл
нашої країни на дві частини так званий
корейський сценарій 38-го паралель вот
але ми на це не можемо піти тому що тоді
ми будемо мати
країну яка буде мати постійно точку от
яка не буде стабільною от а
дестабілізація це питання номер один для
Російської Федерації Я хочу щоб ми з
вами всією свідомо розуміли що якщо буде
такий варіант то не про розвиток нашої
країни молитися не може На які дві
частини Вони хотіли поділити Україну Ну
у них їх мрія це Донецька Луганська
область
Запорізька Херсонська відповідно Крим це
те мрії їх по суходолу мати шлях до
Криму вони зараз будуть вдаватися до
шантажу вони зараз будуть максимально
активізуватись шантажем ядерної зброї ну
це звична річ для цієї країни от яка є
країна терористом на чолі з терористами
Як ви думаєте наскільки їм вдасться
просунутись під час свого як вже багато
разів анонсувалося такого більшого
наступу
активізація наступу вже триває крайний
тиждень вони його розпочали от Він не є
для них вдалим вони намагалися ще
починаючи десь з
10-11 лютого Все це розпочати але
завдяки нашим збройним силам силам який
оборонять нашу країну на території
Донецької Луганської області на
території Запорізької області цей план у
них на сьогоднішній день дає як то
кажуть збій от я буду далі розгортатися
події будемо дивитися от ми точно
розуміємо що ми максимально готові до
всіх цих речей але я хочу зауважити що
це війна на превеликий жаль ще раз
наголошує кожного дня на цій війні
гинуть наші кращі і з кращих от ну така
доля ми маємо виборювати нашу
незалежність і обговорювати нашу свободу
І те що на сьогоднішній день
відбувається що вже 54 країни приймають
участь у Rammstein це показник того що
правда і справедливість на нашому боці
на боці Росії на сьогоднішній день
тільки Іран
Ну і
там країна може бути Африки які зараз
дуже потужна Росія хоче залучити до
якоїсь співпраці там
Лавров Міністра закордонних справ він
там не вилазить зараз з Африки вони
хочуть залучити їх до себе в партнера ну
але ми це бачили лише за радянських
часів Я хочу сказати що якраз радянська
влада була в Африці так був
представництво було
саме в тих регіонах от будемо дивитися
ви вже задали про підтримку заходу Як ви
оцінюєте допомогу від Заходу і Наскільки
змінилася свідомість західних партнерів
за останній рік на вашу думку Німеччини
зокрема те що стосується Заходу Я можу
сказати що жодна країна на 24 лютого
22-го року не вірила щоб ми можемо
встояти Це була позиція всіх без
виключно країн всіх їх розвиток хоча
саме в цьому ка я всіх переконував що
вони помиляються коли вони вважають що у
нас немає спроможності і утриматись
утримати ситуацію і дати відсіч
російська федерації у нас такі
спроможності були і вони на сьогоднішній
день є на початку нам було вкрай вкрай
складно і маєте рацію що дійсно за цей
рік от дуже багато
відбулося змін на початку він не у нас
було чотири слова От їх знали майже
кожен громадянин вони були більш для
емоційного такого піднесення Це був In
Love Javelin Стінгер І байрактар от
зараз в зелених військових
військовому напрямку зброї обладнання от
він набагато ширше от зараз є повністю
зміна от Вона відбулася в цьому процесі
в тому числі і те що стосується
Німеччини Я хочу нагадати коли
починалася багато лунала про 5 допомога
про 5000 казок які нам Німеччина обіцяла
надати в якості допомоги і зараз ми
знаємо що вже прийняте рішення те що
стосується важкої техніки те що
стосуються танків леопардів Ми дуже
вдячні от німцям за те що вони
врешті-решт почали розуміти що перехід
на сторону світла Він дуже важливий от в
сучасному світі і маючи історичний
паралелі які відбувалися в XX сторіччі
от в 30-х 40-х роках Я думаю що німці як
ніхто мають розуміти що таке
справедливість і ми ще раз наголошуємо
що ми вдячні зараз
німецькому керівництву що вони зараз
стали на обох світла на боці світла і що
зараз така допомога буде набагато більша
ніж була на початку війни
Ви вже сказали що 24 лютого можуть бути
знову масовані ракетні обстріли до того
ви говорили про те що у Росії потенціалу
збройного ще на 2-3 масовані обстріли
але вони вже були як ви оцінюєте зараз
російський ресурси Ну я хочу щоб ми з
вами згадали те що стосується
обстрілів ми ведемо облік дуже
ретельно всього що відбувається масово
не обстрілом ми маємо на увазі коли
одноразово відправляються 100 120 ракет
як це бувало зараз вони набагато менше
відправляють крайні обстріли який був
позавчора
в наш бік було відправлено 32 ракети От
вже нема таких скажемо так от по 100
зараз вони на жаль роблять
переобладнання от певної
певного виду озброєння От і ще раз
наголошую Ми свідомі того що є на
території Російської Федерації от ми
розуміємо кількість високоточних ракет
які там на сьогоднішній день лишилися
вони дійсно знаходяться в набагато
меншому стані ніж було на 24 лютого
деяких ракет залишилися 8% деяких 11%
порівняно з тим що було
Це точно не є для них
позитивне позитивним моментом єдина
ситуація яка нас дуже турбує яку ми на
сьогоднішній день
намагаємося не допуститися якщо
Російська Федерація буде надаватися
допомога саме ракетами з боку Ірану або
якийсь інших країн які мають Скажімо так
от авторитарний або тоталітарний режим а
8-10% від їхнього потенціалу це скільки
в цифрах можете назвати це залежності
від того які це є ракети одних лишилися
8% інших лишилися 11% Я би не хотів
зараз назвати цифри от робота більш така
тонка наших фахівців які працюють на
цьому напрямку Повірте у вищого
військово-політичного керівництва є
повна інформація і ми її отримаємо
щоденне і щоденна президент нашої країни
Верховного командуючий проінформований
про стан справ що відбувається в
російському оборонно-промисловому
комплексі Що відбувається подивитися в
російських залишках на засідання ставки
Верховного команду що який відбувається
щонайменше два три рази на тиждень всі
ці питання постійно знаходиться на
контролі вони проговорюються і ми
розуміємо з яким
ворогом нам
зараз Ми змушені воювати а що робиться в
українському оборонопромисловому
комплексі кажу стосується нашого
оборонопромислового комплексу він вже
відрізняється від того що відбувалося на
початку війни дуже багато є розуміння що
треба робити от більш того є співпраця з
країнами НАТО і на
частини цих країн вже віртуальності
спільного виробництва тих чи інших
засобів ураження от іде потужна робота і
я хочу сказати що наш комплекс
забезпечує тими речами які є абсолютно
перфектними з точки зору використання Я
хочу нагадати коли 13-14 квітня
відправлений туди він пішов за
призначенням російський Корабель під
назвою Москва то це були Саме так наші
українські ракети це були наше
виробництво і я дякую всім хто в цьому
приймав участь е-е От і коли казали що
ми до чогось там не готувалися Щось
наробили то яскраво підтвердження що це
зовсім не відповідає дійсності якраз те
що саме нашими українськими ракетами
нептунами було дум'яни тунами був
відправлений те що вважалося взагалі
ніколи би в житті не мали би відправити
тоді ми Їх відправили агентство на
Rammstein сказав що от по боєприпасах те
що потребує Україна не вистачає ні у них
Ні не встигають виробляти
що буде з боєприпасами коли ми наприклад
підемо в Контрнаступ Коли Україна зможе
піти в Контрнаступ І що для цього
потрібно
для цього потрібно боєприпаси ми
розуміємо який спосіб Вони мають у нас
з'явитися
єдине Я хотів би зауважити коли якщо це
відповідає дійсності те що ви кажете що
нема спроможності виготовляти боєприпаси
якщо каже панство то в мене питання А як
вони тоді збиралися взагалі захищати
свої країни над Це щось не ну не зовсім
Я думаю що відповідає дійсності Я думаю
що або журналісти не так почули п
стовбурга або він щось сплутав не може
країни НАТО не забезпечувати от
боєприпасами себе скажемо так у разі
загрози от я ще раз наголошую дуже
уважно треба дивитися чи насправді було
так як ми на сьогоднішній день з вами
трактуємо те що стосується забезпечення
боєприпасами от ви знаєте що були так
звані боєприпаси Радянського Союзу
калібру 122 152 мм вони майже
закінчилися майже у всьому світі тому
тому що такого
обсягу використання боєприпасів такої
війни ніхто не очікував я можу точно вам
з певності сказати що
рік війни за який Було використано дуже
величезну кількість і бойоприпасів іншої
скажемо так от техніки в жодному
прогнозі жодних аналітичних центрів в
світі не існувало крім те що ми
прогнозували те що ми їм доводили Але на
превеликий жаль вони нам не вірили вони
вважали що ми
не володіємо
ситуацію яка є на Росії
їх спроможності от ми довели що це не
зовсім так і ми достатньо інформовані
були ще на початку
з січня місяця на початку лютого от ми
розуміли коли там що які рухи
відбувалися і були максимально готові до
тих чи інших процесів Коли Україна піде
у Контрнаступ
коли військові будуть вважати за
необхідне Коли вони будуть вважати що
вони для цього мають всі необхідні
ресурси це обов'язково буде год зроблена
більш того Я Хочу наголосити що ми
обов'язково маємо звільнити цю територію
нашої країни включно з Кримом ми
повернемо собі кордони 91-го року я
комусь щось не хотілося Чому Тому що
якщо ми цього не зробимо ще раз
наголошую Тоді питання нестабільності в
нашому регіоні воно буде На порядку
денному і тоді розвиток нашої держави
неможливий тому що це пов'язані речі
ніхто не буде вкладати в територію на
які не закінчені конфлікт я можу сказати
чому не вкладається інвестиції в Молдову
тому що там існує постійний Скажімо так
конфлікт який свого часу Росія туди
внесла так звана Придністров'я яке немає
ніякого відношення до
Молдови зробили окремий анклав у Молдова
буде цілісна наша країна цілісна Грузія
буде цілісна тоді почнеться розвиток
Якщо у вас є всередині країни така
невирішена ситуація то Майте на увазі що
не треба обманювати не себе не населення
і нас нам не треба Скажімо так щоби
захід нас е-е воду в обману щоб вони
будуть вкладати інвестиції в країну в
якій не вирішена остаточне питання
стабільності вкладають гроші тільки
стабільній території от ви вже задали
про Молдову і про Грузію я тоді по
порядку запитаю от останні дні ми бачимо
активізацію певних процесів в Білорусії
і Молдові що це відбувається і для чого
Чи хочуть відтягнути увагу України щоб
перекинути війська розтягнути на інші
два фронти ще маєте рацію абсолютно тут
не треба бути
великим оракулом от для того щоб
розуміти що саме для цього Росія і
робить спроби у них був план те що
стосується дестабілізації в готові
ситуації
наша одна із наших розвідок мала повний
цей план і ми передали нашим партнерам
нашим друзям
Молдову цей план куди стабілізації
ситуації і те що стосується ситуації
пов'язана з Білорусією яка на
сьогоднішній день я окупована Російською
Федерацією вже довгий проміжок часу так
само вони максимально спробують
активізати там процеси для того щоб ми
її відтягнули частину нашого війська як
на молдавський напрямок так і на
білоруський напрямок от сьогодні
відбувається зустріч коли ми з вами
спілкуємося
Лукашенка з Путіним Я думаю що це буде
ще один одна спроба
примусити Лукашенка прийняти активну
участь але вчора він зробив заяву що
вони можуть прийняти участь тільки у
разі якщо ми будемо проявляти агресію в
нас агресії по відношенню до території
Білорусії до її громадян ніякої немає те
що стосується окремих тем елементів От
ще раз наголошую у нас в плані нападати
Білорусію немає як і планів нападати на
будь-яку країну ми демократична країна
ми визнаємо кордони тих країн які були
зафіксовані на 91-й рік це Росія до нас
вдяглася от забрала спочатку Крим от
світ промовчав потім зробили Ну от
військовий злочин світ промовчав ну а
зараз маємо наслідки цього цього
мовчання чому на вашу думку не
активізується Грузія адже Зараз якраз
шанс для неї звільнити і свої окуповані
території ви
пам'ятаєте що я на початку березня як
почалася ця війна я мав цього приводу
публічний виступ Я вважав що якщо
грузини вважають що частина їх території
є окупована росіяни саме час зараз
розпочати боротьбу за відновлення
територіальної цілості цінності Грузії
був з боку Грузії такі
закиди мій бік що я намагаюся
внутрішні справи розбирайтеся самостійно
але те що на сьогоднішній день вплив
Російської федерації на керівництво
Грузії є величезний це вже відомо всім у
світі от як довго це буде продовжити Ну
це справа взагалі-то грузин от була дуже
дивна заява Президент Грузії от стосовно
того що вони мають Скажем так поставити
в умови от е-е війни закінчення війни
звільнення території Грузії ну така
трошечки знаєте я хочу сказати Я з
великої повагою шанна і вдячністю до
всіх
громадян Грузії які на сьогоднішній день
на боці світла
які воюють спільно з нашими хлопцями і
дівчатами з
фашистськими рашистами от але я мав
розуміння що Грузія може мала б трошечки
по-іншому собі в даному випадку
проводити і щодо повернення
окупованих тимчасово окупованих
територій чи пропрацьовується зараз
кроки як потім
повертати цій території і людей які там
живуть в українській дискурсуд що з
людьми будуть робити чи є якийсь
механізм
питання от я вже мав відповідь на це
питання Я не розумію що ви маєте на
увазі коли кажете українські дискус є
територія країни на території країни є
дія конституції України є дія законів
України якщо комусь не подобається наша
конституція не подобається наші закони
він вільно може пересуватися в світі він
бере собі Скажімо так свої речі бере
свої валізу і відправляється Куди він
вважає за необхідне там де його
влаштовує закони влаштовує Конституцію
влаштовують ті норми і правила якщо
вважають що вся країна має
підлаштовуватися під яку невеличку групу
людей то це абсолютно хибна Скажімо так
от уявлення про процеси це не про
демократія це зовсім про інші про інші
речі ще раз наголошую Кому подобається
наша країна наша Земля наші закони наші
Конституції
будь ласка радий всім Якщо ви вважаєте
що в ванного не подобається Вот маєте
право є багато цікавих місць там калима
Воркута
ухта там ну там там як величезна
величезна кількість от Можете поїхати і
там спробувати наладити нове життя про
те що не всі люди поїдуть але на тих
територіях які окуповані вже понад 8
років люди постійно піддавались
пропагандії і як будуть працювати з ними
як Україна буде їх повертати дивіться
коли ви кажете що
Пропаганда вісім років таке інше якщо
людина не склеїла ніяких злочинів якщо
він не є вбився якщо він неправ мав
участь катунії наших е-е громадян якщо
за ним нема ніякого криміналу він живе
собі спокійним життям і ніколи
переховувати ми нікого не збираємося це
не наше завдання кожна людина живе як
заважає за необхідне коли ви вважаєте що
ви когось можете переоховати я можу
сказати по своїй практиці от діда який
має 9 онуків ви можете
виховувати онуків до 3-5 років якщо буде
цього часу їх не виховали то далі
переоховувати вже марна справа це
по-перше а по-друге витрачати час когось
Скажімо так в чомусь
комусь щось пояснювати Ну і я не знаю
для чого Бо тоді ми знову програємо
інформаційну війну на тих територіях
дивіться ніякої інформаційну війну ми не
програємо тому що та Пропаганда яка була
як тільки зникне Пропаганда як раз а на
сонці так відразу зникнути всі ці
наративи які на сьогоднішній день є А
якщо хтось собі в голову вклав що тут
фашисти що тут Скажімо так от інші
угрупування які вони самі собі вигадали
то це точно не про нас тут ніяких
фашистів сидять в Кремлі перші фашист на
сьогоднішній день це Путін вот при чому
я можу сказати що коли
був тариф номер один у саме Бен Ладен то
на сьогоднішній день в світі Турист №1 -
це Путін Я хочу щоб ми всі це розуміли
коли кажуть що ви маєте терористами
сідати за стіл переговорів і про що я з
ними говорити Ну послухайте Ну тоді
Сполучені Штати після 11 вересня мали б
сісти з Бен ладе нам за стіл перемовин
От і про щось з ним домовлятися
ну це несправедливо туристів треба
знищувати Давайте поговоримо про останні
корупційні скандали в Міноборони
податковій яка реакція заходу до них і
як Це вплинуло на репутацію України те
що стосується корупційних скандалів Як
ви називаєте міністерстві оборони Я не
хочу нікого відбілювати Я не хочу казати
що там всі білі і пухнасті але те що там
ми рано чи пізно побачимо з вами
російські слід от чи то серед виконавців
чи то серед замовників чи в якомусь
іншому процесі я Повірте ми з вами це
дізнаємося от це по-перше по-друге це
дійсно Для нас це е-е пляма от яку ми
маємо обов'язково зробити світло світлою
Ми не маємо права Скажімо так от зробити
вигляд що цього не відбувається це
виклик і ми обов'язково поставимо всі
крапки Нади для того щоб люди розуміли
що відбувалося І що відбувається і ніхто
нікого не буде покривати не нікого не
Скажімо так от приховувати це стосується
будь-яких інституцій і немає значення
яку вони мають назву ще раз нашу для нас
публічність процесор от публічність
відносин і в нашими партнерами і з
нашими громадянами це питання номер один
і Володимир Олександрович зробив відразу
після цього заяву і подякував
журналістам ті які приймали участь в
цьому розслідуванні коли ми будемо з
вами мати остаточний вердіт тоді Будемо
розуміти як все це відбувалося ми маємо
побудувати таку систему яка унеможливо
на майбутнє будь-яких дій будь-яких
шахрайських процесів пов'язаний те що
стосується гроші держави це гроші наші
громадян це гроші наші спільні всі і
ніхто не має права в цю кишеню нашу
спільну кишеню запускати свої грязні
руки Як ви думаєте коли Могло б бути
розслідування і притягнення до
відповідальності Я би дуже хотів щоб
люди і відповідали для того щоб цього не
відбулося і вони так само за це несли
відповідальність От коли це буде ми з
вами побачимо вот я буду дуже хотів щоб
у нас не було такого скажемо так Коли
відбулися перші певні події а потім
проходити роки люди забувають що там
відбувалися таке інше як я б хотів щоб
наші органи працювали в даному випадку
тому що це буде запит суспільства дати
чітко відповідь як це відбувалося
дотичний тут який Скажімо так от
депутати дотичні тут якісь Скажімо так
родичі депутатів або якісь інші ще раз
наголошую ніякого табу з боку президента
ви з цього приводу не побачите
максимальне публічності і відкритість
відкрити всіх процесів які я на
сьогоднішній день чи буде Україна
збільшувати свій мобілізаційний ресурс
ми 24 лютого почали в перший день
восьмий годині ранку було проголосовано
в Верховній Раді я мав безпосередньо
доповідь от загальним мобілізація
ця мобілізація відбувається до цього
часу
наші військові Наші сили безпеки і
оборони які безпосередньо приймають
участь в цьому процесі вони залучають
таку кількість громадян які вважають і
необхідна для виконання тих завдань які
є на сьогодні і ніякої трагедії ніяких
Скажімо так от форс-мажорів вона в
даному випадку немає вона іде у нас за
планом спокійно рівно виважена і вже
буде рік Ви не бачили Скажімо так такого
щоб було би якось там е-е речей які
виходили за межі чи є поодинокі випадки
там де люди не з повна розуму роблять ті
речі які точно робити не треба Ну це
трапляється але це поодинокі випадки Я
хочу звернути увагу що це не є якась
масована така ситуація те що стосується
[музика]
і починає щось там якісь насінитності
собі розповідати у нас зовсім інше
суспільство і ми готові до будь-якого
виклику пане Данило ви казали що саме
Україна розвалила СРСР чи вдасться
Україні розводити реф події які
відбувалися почали відбуватися 2 березня
Воркуті це був початок от розвалу
України які вважали що ніколи не
розвалилися більш того я можу сказати
коли першого серпня 91-го року один із
президентів Сполучених Штатів перебував
тут у нас в Києві і робив заяву в нашому
парламенті що нам ні в якому разі не
можна жити окремим життям от а потім
через 18 днів відбулося кчп і ще через
короткий проміжок часу СРСР припинив
своє існування це кажуть про те що на
заході не до кінця розуміють як взагалі
працюють ці процеси Російська Федерація
буде розвалена от вона повернулися от
бажає того на заході і або не бажає Вони
мають до цього готуватися і свої крайні
статті як і я дав Українську правду я
попередив що захід має готуватися до
розпаду Російської Федерації в тому
вигляді в якому вона є Вона існувати вже
не буде старт цьому розвалу дав Путін 24
лютого якщо би Путін не дав став розвалу
Росії 24 лютого Росія може ще певний
бичав існувала в тих межах це буде
зовсім інша країна за своїми межами буде
окреме ечкерія Вільна країна буде
окремий Дагестан він ідегістан Татарстан
і багато інших територій які оберуть
шлях Свободи Незалежності і свого
власного майбутнього вони самі ці народи
а там саме народ вони самостійно будуть
вирішувати своє питання як їм жити З ким
він там харчувати як їм розвиватися тощо
і ще раз наголошую треба розуміти що
процеси які вони вважають що Москва буде
контролювати все і вся Вони не працюють
як приклад я можу навести хабаровську
якому були Скажімо так певні процеси які
ніхто довгі проміжок часу не міг Скажімо
так заспокоїти не міг контролювати як
тільки буде перша
заворушення От
після цього процес ланцюгова реакція
піде по всій Росії і цього буде не
зупинити і ще раз тож захід має зараз
готуватися до розпаду Росії в тому
вигляді в якому вона на сьогоднішній
день є якщо він цього не зробить Він
зробить помилку які вони зробили в 91-му
році От коли вони вважали що такого не
станеться і робочого все буде
підконтролями він буде далі Скажімо так
продовжувати нібито будувати там якусь
демократичну СРСР ну чим наслідки ми
бачимо на сьогоднішнього дня дякуємо вам
за розмову